i was rooting for you we were all rooting for you
it's michelle from lab muffin
beauty science here chemistry
phd skincare nerd and beauty marketing connoisseur
the inkey list are a brand that i
generally quite like they're probably
the main competitor to the ordinary which
i also quite like both brands have lots
of products and there are lots of products
from both brands that work well on my skin
they're both also really budget friendly and
it's hard to hate brands that are making skin
care more financially accessible both brands
are also quite sciencey in their marketing so
they put their ingredient names front and
center and i think that's gone a long way
towards making everyone more comfortable with
using synthetic chemicals that they might not
be able to pronounce very easily they have sort
of scary-ish names the whole natural is better
don't use ingredients you can't pronounce thing
i think really took a blow thanks to these brands
recently the inkey list released a new
product the succinic acid acne treatment
you've probably seen it all over social media
inkey are really busting out the marketing
budget for this release and honestly i like
this product a lot it's been working really
well for breakouts i've gotten i put it on
and overnight it does seem to calm down a lot
but i'm finding the marketing around this product
kind of shady and i'm going to explain why
if you like this sort of nerdy
beauty content click the like
the subscribe and the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
so first off this is not a bad product like
i said it works really well on me and i think
there are very few truly bad products on the
market but there is a lot of dodgy marketing
i've been blogging about beauty products
since 2011 so i've had a lot of time to
read the press releases about new
products and i've gotten used to the
sorts of marketing tricks that brands use
i'm not sure if it's intentional but the
marketing around the inkey list succinic
acid acne treatment is kind of genius
let's start by talking about succinic
acid succinic acid is usually used
as a ph adjuster or chelating agent in
products so it's playing a supporting role
it's not really an active it has almost
no peer-reviewed studies on it for acne
there are two papers on pubmed where
succinic acid and acne are both mentioned
and they're from the same research group the 2016
paper isn't actually really about succinic acid
the 2014 paper is the one where they actually did
studies on it basically staphylococcal epidermidis
bacteria compete with c acnes bacteria on your
skin neither of them are really good or bad
they both contribute to acne but they both
also protect your skin against infections
from other microbes they both live inside
acne pimples and they're battling each other
succinic acid is one of the chemicals that the
staph bacteria might be using to keep the c acnes
bacteria in check the researchers put succinic
acid with c acnes bacteria on one of these glass
plates they found that they needed a concentration
of five millimolar to kill the bacteria for
comparison they needed twice as much lactic acid
and 50 percent more acetic acid acetic acid is the
acid that you find in vinegar then they injected
c acnes bacteria into mouse ears to make them
inflamed like a pimple would be then they injected
succinic acid into them and they found that both
the number of bacteria and the inflammation
decreased finally they decided to skin care some
mouse ears so they injected the c acnes bacteria
again and then they applied about one percent
succinic acid onto them and they found that again
the bacteria counts and the inflammation decreased
now this is pretty promising but this is far
from enough evidence to say that it actually
works against acne as a drug ingredient if you're
familiar with medicinal chemistry then you'll know
that there are millions and millions of compounds
that work well on cells and on animals but then
they never turn out to be a drug because
things that work well in cells and animals
don't necessarily work well on humans in real life
the conditions on your skin are very different
from the conditions on glass or on an animal
that's why you read about cures for cancer being
found in amazon rainforests and then you never
hear about them again it's not because big pharma
is suppressing the information it's because that
headline is based on in vitro or animal studies
and it never actually got tested on humans that's
why the just says in mice twitter account exists
there's also data from the chemical company
that sells the succinic acid to brands showing
that it decreases sebum but there are basically
no details on how the study was done and a lot
of supplier studies are pretty low quality
so they'll have really small sample sizes
and sometimes the protocols are a bit rigged in
the ingredients favor so it doesn't tell us much
the inkey list marketing material also says that
succinic acid has been in european medical circles
for a while now this has been repeated in a
lot of magazines but it's a really ambiguous
statement and i haven't heard back from inkey list
about what that actually means i don't think it
means that it's being used by european doctors
to treat their patients for acne i've asked a
few derms and they've said they've never heard
of it and we saw the complete lack of evidence
before in the pubmed search results so based on
all of this it isn't really surprising that no
one's heard of succinic acid before clearly no
big brands are excited enough about it to put it
as the star ingredient in their products a lot
of ingredient checker sites don't even have a
listing for it inkey have chosen an ingredient
that they pretty much have a monopoly on
this is nothing new a lot of brands do choose
ingredients that no one else is using because
then there's a novelty factor and they can get
people excited about their particular product
and putting ingredients into products that
don't have a lot of evidence behind them
again is nothing new it happens all the time
and in general i think it's a good thing if
everything had to be tested properly then
we would all be using about three products
to me the big difference is that this product
is actually regulated as a drug in the US if you
turn the packaging over you can actually see the
drug facts label that's why inkey are allowed to
have the word acne in the name of their product
front and center acne is a medical condition and
you're only allowed to make products that claim to
treat medical conditions if they're drugs so this
is an over-the-counter drug just like sunscreen
you don't need a prescription to buy it but it
has a special status it has this special status
because it contains an ingredient that's been
scientifically vetted to work and that ingredient
is salicylic acid which is over here in size 4
font on the legally required label it's up here
it's got top billing whereas succinic acid is over
here under inactive ingredients but you wouldn't
know it if you're looking at the product name the
product packaging the description of the product
all the marketing around the product how everyone
is talking about it whether it's the beauty media
sponsored influencers or unsponsored influencers
succinic acid is always talked about like it is
the top active ingredient that's treating the acne
and not the actual active ingredient it's called
the lead ingredient salicylic acid is supporting
this sort of marketing around fluff
ingredients is pretty basic standard
misleading beauty marketing 101 that you
learn about the moment you start getting
into skincare it's where brands put a tiny
sprinkle of exotic jamaican sparkle flower
into their product and then you turn it
over and it turns out it's full of retinol
but it doesn't happen a lot with actual skin care
drugs and i don't know if it's because people
realize that this would be pretty deceptive it's
like a drug claiming it's a herbal painkiller and
you flip it over and it actually has codeine in
it or if you have a sunscreen that calls itself a
mineral sunscreen and then in size 4 font it has
oxybenzone and avobenzone actually that analogy
doesn't work that well because at least zinc
oxide is an actual approved sunscreen filter so
let's do raspberry oil there are lots of people
who genuinely think that raspberry oil is a good
sunscreen because in one in vitro study with a
dodgy protocol it came out with an spf of 28 to 50
so it's like a sunscreen that calls itself a
raspberry oil sunscreen but it also has standard
amounts of oxybenzone and avobenzone in it on the
front the oxybenzone and avobenzone is in size 4
font but the marketing is all about how amazing
raspberry oil is for sun protection it's the next
big thing lots of doctors in europe have been
using it for decades and then it says there are
these supporting players avobenzone and oxybenzone
now inkey may genuinely believe that succinic acid
is amazing for acne and it is the star player
and maybe it is the star player but they're not
legally allowed to say that the level of evidence
for succinic acid doesn't let them say this
i mean it's a pretty interesting ingredient
but with no peer reviewed studies that have
actually used it on human skin it's pretty
dodgy that it's being marketed like it's a drug
that is less evidence than a lot of ingredients
that we think are sort of fluffy so things
like bakuchiol and snail secretion those
actually have multiple peer reviewed studies
on human skin to do it properly inkey should be
submitting succinic acid for proper drug approval
so this involves rigorous trials on human skin
rather than just on 10 mouse ears if they d
o that then succinic acid can join salicylic
acid in that top box but obviously this is very
expensive but they're in a loophole where
it's a sort of gray area and they don't
actually have to do this because everyone's
already assuming that succinic acid is a drug
that it is actively treating acne succinic acid
is on the packaging right next to the word acne
it's impossible to miss and you can see that this
marketing is working really well if you look at
articles in the beauty media succinic acid is the
acne ingredient you should be using succinic acid
is not an acne ingredient this specific product
is an acne treatment because it has salicylic
acid but that doesn't mean all of the ingredients
in this are acne ingredients they don't have the
level of evidence for that that's why they're in
the bottom box with the label inactive ingredients
i wouldn't be anywhere near as annoyed if inkey
just changed the name of their product and
changed up the marketing a bit so that salicylic
acid was less of an afterthought let's say they
called it the triple threat acne treatment with
salicylic acid succinic acid and sulfur not all
of their products have a single ingredient in the
name so why didn't they do that maybe they wanted
to highlight how great they think succinic acid is
but maybe it's actually the cleverest part of this
at the moment inkey have a monopoly on succinic
acid no one else uses it as their star ingredient
and no one snuck it into a drug product by
using a different active drug ingredient the
way this is played out is that people hear that
succinic acid is great for acne they google it
and conveniently the only product
that's made for acne with succinic acid
is the inkey list one if they used salicylic
acid as the headline ingredient then you would
come up with tons and tons of products but
because no one else is doing this then inkey
have basically made sure that all of this
traffic searching for succinic acid ends up
with this product even if it
ends up promoting misinformation
i don't know if inkey are marketing geniuses or
they accidentally stumbled onto this strategy
but it is working really well step 1 make a
product that's classified as a drug because
of well-tested ingredients that every other
brand is already using step 2 put the medical
condition in the name of the product next to a
little-known ingredient the less evidence for
it the better because you'll have a search
monopoly step 3 promote the crap out of the
product you barely have to exaggerate because the
product name does it for you every media outlet
or influencer who talks about the product has to
say the name and that ingrains that relationship
between the ingredient and the medical
condition in everyone's minds step 4 profit
i suspect a lot of brands are going to try to
copy this because it is working so well for
inkey that's why i decided to make this video even
though i realized it might be a bit controversial
so we can spot brands doing this
in the future and call them out
again i don't know if this was actually their
intention but the net effect is that everyone
is being led to believe that succinic acid is an
evidence-backed ingredient for treating acne it is
an actual drug that treats a medical condition and
for me the worst part is i really like inkey list
i really resonate with their values i really
like their emphasis on knowledge and education
and it is a perfectly good product
it works really well everyone is
gushing about it it didn't need this i was
rooting for you we were all rooting for you
so in conclusion this is a good product but
it has bad marketing it's misleading maybe
it's not intentionally deceptive
but that is the overall effect
so that's what i think i don't know what are
your thoughts let me know in the comments what
do you think about inkey list what do you think
about this specific product and the marketing
i hope you liked this video if you did click the
thumbs up and the subscribe you can also follow
me on instagram and check out my blog for more
beauty science see you next time to nerd out more